vous avez déjà pris vont à très très
gros râteau à m sila dit la vérité moi
ouais ouais ouais c'était quoi sur le
râteau non mais en fait moi j'ai testé
ça c'était le meilleur ami moi j'étais
toujours le meilleur pote
ah ouais ouais moi je ramenais les
gouttes et les goûter mais j'avais
jamais le droit de goûter moi je suis
sûr que la bnrm benzema va coûter deux
mois déjà
nantes la place des râteaux toi tu a
galéré
j'avais c'est pas en tête connais tu as
pris des ça remonte à dix ans ont
rencontré ma femme
ah ouais râteau direct à ta femme a time
et râteaux elle m'avait mis une croix
tournoi elle n'aimait pas les balades
[Rires]
qua non mais sérieux et après ça c'est
mais c'est pas mal ça t'a motivé c'est
bien mais où exactement je te jure que
c'est vrai que c'est ça de garoua j'ai
pris 4 à taux et daniel moment je ne
lâche pas vous mais moi ce dernier rate
of à moi j'en ai tellement que c'est
leur deal en revanche est quoi ce
dernier a tout raté
cependant pas le dernier non le plus fou
très très anciens j'étais tout jeune et
1920 voilà et pour une fois j'ai craqué
pour pour à quelqu'un qui était un tout
petit peu plus âgés que moi ça et il m'a
invité midi avec violette invité parce
que je voudrais dire un secret tout donc
la saline l'homme et chez patou c'est en
fait c'est très sec et qu'il était
amoureux de ma meilleure amie
non il aimait que je l'aide pour havas
et elle était blonde un peu comme kelly
donc maintenant je n'ai plus d'amis
blonde je le conte la vie plus vieilles
et contrôler la vérité qui quoi moi j'en
ai pris en haussant cependant
vercingétorix est à la campagne dans le
dauphiné et il y avait un agriculteur
que je trouvais magnifique en vrai et un
jour je vois qu'il va passer et je me
suis dit ouh là là je vais me mettre
devant je sors avec une petite robe que
je pensais affriolants et il y avait un
vrai râteau devant moi je marche on
estime dans qui passe je me le prends et
je tombe dans une brouette à la renverse
et comme je me fais tellement vite que
exceptionnellement une fois dans ma vie
j'ai pas le temps de mettre une culotte
le mec il fasse devant moi et 10 les
foules c'est comme les champignons ces
mots bis in quand ça se voit trop vite à
des bateaux vous étonner mais je n'ai
pas eu beaucoup de râteau à un seul à
winnezeele maintenant c'est moi qui
donne les râteaux ait accroché pas mal
de propositions et ccc se sont défaits à
veux tu aller boire un verre j'ai dit
désolé je vais beaucoup de travail là
dessus mais ça que les râteaux c'est
très compliqué avec ses mains à
l'échauffement toutefois d'expliquer des
râteaux oui une fois alors c'est quoi
c'est avec une fille qui s'appelait
margot je me rappelle c'était un pote
qui m'avait donné l'occasion de la
rencontrer on s'était vus deux fois des
fois c'était au cinéma on passa
magnifiques repas un petit burger que je
lui ai offert d'ailleurs et puis ensuite
on est je me suis rares on l'a ramené
jeu les ramener au métro et mon pote me
dis il faut absolument que tu n'en
prince où elle est elles prennent lé là
c'était la deuxième fois qu'on se voyait
donc j'ai le coeur qui battait à la smad
in auquel annie et c'est drôle avec
maxime j'aime beaucoup moi me fait rire
mais en fait compte dès qu'il parle tu
sais il il a la voix du suspense du loto
la hausse et les noms d'alain lebeau le
bon tour avec sa grille il a oublié de
dire au revoir je m'approche je
l'embrassais là elle a fait un pas en
arrière
alors je me retrouve ma voix qui
guérissent pas et donc et puis on sait
jamais revue elle a été un peu offusqué
de mon nom entreprises
et puis voilà c'est à m'aider dans ses
locaux